I've started out by just writing L2 minus L1. And we can notice that both of
these have a factor of 10. So let's just go ahead and pull that out. So
factoring out that 10 and then also distributing this minus sign to both terms
inside the second parenthesis, gives us this. 10 times log of 2P minus log of
B. Minus log of P plus log of B. Something that pops out in this expression is
that we have a minus log of B and a plus log of B. So these two things are
going to cancel each other out, awesome. That's how we get rid of that B and
that's why we didn't need to know its actual value. Looking at what this
equations reduces to then, we can see how much simpler everything is. We still
however have another variable left in here. What do we do with this P? Well I
think that we have to bring back our quotient rule again. But this time we are
going to use it in the reverse order from how we did before. We're going to
condense this expression into just a single log. This gives us 10 times log
base 10 of 2P over P. Well, and look at that, if we divide 2P by P, these Ps
just cancel each other out. That's going to leave us with something super easy.
10 times log base 10 of 2. This is just a number, let's use the calculator to
evaluate this. We have 10 times log base 10 of 2. That's equal to 3.01 etc.
Which I'm going to round to just 3, so our answer is about 3 decibels.